(hums and laughs)
(dance music)
- My life is being made right now so much.
(whooshes and squeaks)
(soft rock music)
- Hi everyone, I'm Emma
Bunton form the Spice Girls
and I'm here to freak out some fans.
- I was and I am and I will remain
a gigantic Spice Girls
fan my whole entire life.
It's like mainly the reason that I feel
like a confident woman in my life.
- I actually live my life
according to like the philosophy
of the Spice.
- I had a Spice Girls
themed birthday party
where I only invited enough people
to fill out the Spice Girls.
- And they were just like the first girls
that I could like identify
with as adolescent slash tween.
- I had all the dolls I had
all the little like fan books.
I had like a Spice World movie thing,
I had the Polaroid camera.
- I had their posters on my wall
and learned all their dance routines.
- The spice girls were legit my life.
- If I could say one
thing to the Spice Girls
it would be,
- Honestly this is gonna sound so cheesy
but it would be thank you.
- Thank you so much for existing.
- Thank you for making me a
powerful, empowered woman.
- You were a huge part of my childhood.
- Alright,
- [Emma] That is nice.
(gasps)
- No!
I'm sorry to yell at you.
- I want to say thank you.
- Maybe like a zig-a-zig ah or something?
- What?
The how?
Why are you so cute?
- Why are you so cute?
- Oh my god.
- I'm still so brightly colored.
- Oh my god
(laughs)
oh my god.
Oh my god.
- What are you doing here?
- I can't believe you said my name.
(laughs)
- And for (screams)
- What a do you mean?
- Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god,
Oh my god.
- Okay, I'm freaking out.
- [Emma] Nice to see you.
- Hi.
- Can I hug you?
- Yes, let's hug it out.
- Ah.
- Zig-a-zig ah.
- Oh my god.
Pause, no.
(laughs)
- Oh my god.
- I love your stories.
- Oh my god I feel like
I'm really gonna cry.
- I just can't even believe
that I'm literally sitting here right now.
- The Spice Girls mean everything to me
and continue to mean everything to me
and I really think that you guys formed
a whole entire generation of women
who believed in themselves because
you existed.
- Can I really just say
like thank you though?
Like I, uh, I don't want
to cry but, whatever.
- Oh my goodness.
- As a young gay kid it was like a thing
of like oh like I'm different and then
I would read about you guys
and what you guys went through
and it was like, you know
what I'm gonna be gay
and I'm gonna own it.
And it was like girl power
and it was like gay power
and latino power.
- Oh my goodness come here.
- I can't believe I'm
next to you right now.
Thank you so much.
- I feel like the Spice Girls
is why I was running around
at 10 years old screaming, girl power.
- What did that feel like to
know that you like influenced
like an era?
- It was an incredible
time but it was amazing
to watch other women support us in the way
that you know, and girls
and as you did, you know,
it was just so nice to
have that support and fans
and people who believed
in what we were doing
and we just felt like we had a message,
we had great music, you know,
just writing our own songs
was really important
to us because we wanted
for you guys to identify
with whatever we wrote.
We feel like we always
want to thank our fans
for being so supportive with us.
- Oh my gosh.
- Ho, my god.
I've so many questions for you.
- She's just looking at me like,
- Do you ever wear big platforms any more?
Like I've so many questions for my,
- Are these platforms, they're kind of,
- Yeah, those are pretty big,
they're not quite as big, okay.
- Not as wide but I broke
my ankles quite a few time
on those things.
- Did you really?
- Yeah I actually did.
- Did you guys really put boogers
under manager's desks and stuff?
(laughs)
- Yes.
- Is that real?
- We did some vile things.
- I love it.
- [Blue Sweater] What's your
favorite Spice Girls' song?
- Two Become One's my favorite I think
but I love Say You'll Be
There is like wow but yeah.
- Yeah that's the best song, oh my god.
This is crazy.
- I'm so grateful for this
experience you don't even know.
- [Emma] It's my pleasure.
- I'm so shaky.
- And I spoke to Geri this morning
and I said that I was doing this
and she was like, oh my god so much fun.
- Can we just go to the
camera and do a girl power?
- Girl power.
- [Both] Girl power.
(laughs)
- What a damn Monday.
- The biggest fight I ever got
into my dad with was whether
the Spice Girls or the Beatles
would go down in history as
the greatest group of all time.
So, (laughs) I'm very dedicated.
I'm gonna have a heart attack.
(laughs)
This, the video will go
viral because it'll be
a Spice Girl killed me.